all right guys I'm here with Emma Emma I
thought a great place to start this
conversation is Kim Kardashian is worth
estimated 1.5 1.7 billion dollar uh I
think most people remember her uh as an
influencer the reality TV star uh they
know that she's built companies but now
she's starting the private Equity Firm
to me the most interesting part about
the private Equity Firm is that she
convinced somebody who is very very
serious very experienced when it comes
to private equity and J Salmons uh to
join her how did she do that well what's
interesting is actually he convinced her
Jay and Kim have known each other for a
decade and he has been following her
career and they've you know uh turned to
each other for business advice and he
had this Insight which is Kim has this
huge platform she's built these
businesses I'm a great investor in the
consumer space if we combine those we
could really do something big and so he
pitched Kim and her mother and manager
Chris Jenner on starting a private
Equity Firm and over several
conversations they decided to actually
do it and get it off the ground where's
the name Sky come from well it does have
the 2ks in the middle so I believe that
is um you know a Kim Kardashian pun her
skincare brand is now called Skin by Kim
so it's skk so kind of the same thing
got it now you've written the first long
form uh profile on uh Sky Partners what
are some of the takeaways that maybe
people who haven't yet read the profile
or haven't really looked into this so
much that caught you by
surprise yeah something that really
resonated with me is I think when Kim
announced that she was starting a
private Equity Firm about a year ago I
think a lot of people kind of perked up
and were interested or maybe surprised
to hear that but when you take a look
back at Kim's career you can really
start to understand how all of what
she's done really does give her the
expertise and skill set and experience
to be able to do something like this um
you know Kim is just really skilled at
understanding the modern consumer and so
whether that's building a consumer
business like she has with skims or just
understanding how consumers interact
with Brands and with influencers and
with companies today on all the various
social platforms we have um she
understands how to reach people and how
to understand what they want and so when
you look back at her career she's had so
many business deals you know every type
licensing deals royalty deals um repping
Brands repping brands that are really
Elite and you know in luxury fashion and
that earlier in her career her first
deals were with Sketchers and the liquor
brand madori sour so she's seen it all
and that is really influencing how she
is approaching what kind of investor she
wants to be so she built a $4 billion
doll company herself but a lot of that
was built off of her influence her
distribution these companies like what
is the strategy is it companies that are
aligned with uh her you know audience
and her platform and she's going to go
and she's going to buy them and then
she'll put them through her distribution
or is this more of a traditional private
Equity play where they're just going to
go buy good companies regardless of
whether they fit you know Kim's
distribution or not and then they'll
scale them up and then sell them to
another private Equity Firm in three to
five years
this is um you know pieces of that
traditional private Equity play uh what
Kim and Jay has said is they are not
building a portfolio of businesses that
look like Kim's businesses you know what
Kim said to me is that a company isn't
going to start working with her fund and
all of a sudden they're um branded all
nude and beige like a Kim branded
company you know referring to skims and
the aesthetic of her apparel brand so
they're looking to invest um in control
and active minority investments in high
growth consumer businesses that they can
really add fuel to the fire and help
reach that next level of success you
know they're looking at media and food
and beverage and Hospitality in addition
to fashion and Beauty where people might
expect Kim to play so there's a lot they
can do here and it's kind of a broader
range than people might think off the
bat when they hear about this now when
we think about her previous businesses
she's been very very involved in them if
they go and they buy a majority stake in
one of these companies do we expect Kim
Kardashian to be CEO kind of heavily
involved or are they going to build out
an entire team other than just Kim and
Jay and this will look you know very
similarly mirrored to a traditional
private Equity Firm where you may have
people focus on specific verticals
you'll be dropping in kind of Hired Guns
as CEO Coos and other
Executives yeah something that Kim says
is really important to her is she really
wants to invest in businesses that are
pretty founder driven she wants the
founder to ideally still be involved or
for the business at least to like really
still have that DNA of the founder if
they've recently left and so I think you
know it's private Equity it's definitely
a Hands-On approach to investing um but
they do say that they want to keep that
founder DNA and not totally just drop in
new teams to
scale got it and now Jay's background uh
you mentioned that he was part of or led
the deal to do the Supreme uh deal at
Carlile he also was involved in the
Beats By Dre um transaction I mean he
has been doing a ton of stuff in and
around culture uh Sports
consumer is this something that is like
crazy to his colleagues or they just
like why are you going and doing this
with Kim Kardashian or is it more of
people being like damn that's a really
good idea I wish I had thought of that
and had that relationship to go
capitalize on it that was one of the
questions I had for him and you know as
he says it's more of the ladder I think
initially there are obviously probably
some people who are like whoa what are
you doing Jay is very well respected in
the field and people um you know look at
the kinds of deals he's done and are
ious why this would be his next move but
I think people are also understand that
you know he had a really unique insight
and they're they're able to really take
advantage of the unique relationship
that Kim and Jay have and you know sky
has so far hired eight people it's hired
from Blackstone and El catterton and
premiera um it's brought on Angela aren
the former Apple SVP and Burberry CEO
who's super well respected in retail and
business so besides Jay other really
successful business folks from private
equity and Beyond are
um agreeing to work on this idea as well
now the check sizes are like1 to $500
million and so uh that suggests that
these are not startups right and I think
even at one point you talked to Kim uh
about she could have done some Venture
Capital stuff but she wants to be much
more involved Hands-On more the private
Equity uh style how many of these
companies are out there for them to look
at if they're going to make eight to 12
Investments over the next four or five
years are there enough consumer uh
companies that are multi-billion dollars
in valuation to actually go and and
potentially look at for investment yeah
I mean hopefully they say they've been
getting a lot of inbound interest since
in since announcing the fund um and some
from brands that are like more mature
than you might expect um not just
startups but um brands that are probably
the same age as some of Kim's companies
and are have come up at the same time
and are you know open to taking on this
kind of capital because they see the
value that Jay Kim and Sky could bring
to their businesses so I mean we'll see
what happens but I mean there are a lot
of successful consumer Brands out there
and when you're looking at the number of
categories that they're looking at
they're defining consumer really broadly
um you know they're not in a rush it's
been a year and they haven't closed that
first deal yet so I think they will be
able to get to that number over the next
few years you've probably spent more
time talking to them and looking into
this than most people well definitely
most people but maybe even more than
almost anyone else um if it doesn't work
what do you think is like the biggest
reason why is there a RIS that stands
out to you as to why something like this
would not work even though you've got
Capital you've got Jay with you know a
great kind of investing track record
you've got Kim both operational and the
influencer like what are the the reasons
why it couldn't work yeah I mean that's
a really interesting question I think
first I would say obviously it's a
tricky Market environment so they have
that up against them folks who I talk to
um in the industry say that you know in
this kind of Market fundraising for
emerging for emerging managers which Sky
would be considered as a firsttime fund
um
is difficult but that kind of the cream
of the crop the elite are able to able
to overcome that and that seems to be
what's happening with sky and then on
the other side there's also the factor
of Kim is a celebrity who her day-to-day
can be influenced by tabloid news and
crazy events and all the attention on
her good and bad so you know there's
always the chance that something could
happen that could affect the way that
sky is perceived in the world but you
know Kim has survived a lot in her 15
plus years of Fame so you know she does
a pretty good job managing it um so
hopefully that would
continue is uh her mom/manager uh Chris
Jenner is she involved at all or is she
uh simply happy for Kim to go do this
and kind of gave her blessing but but
not actually involved in The Firm itself
yeah Chris Jenner is involved in Sky
itself she is a senior adviser for the
fund and an investor as well as Kim and
Jay are also personal investors in the
fund so she was um in the mix right from
the beginning when Jay had the idea he
was pitching both Kim and and Chris
Jenner so she is in the mix and I think
that's another thing the firm has going
for it is Chris has a really unique
expertise as a businesswoman today you
know she's built her family into this
Pinnacle of American success and so that
will be another Advantage for Sky there
there are people who will hear you say
that and roll their eyes but it is true
I think that she now has what two or
three kids who are billionaires and 20
20 years ago no one knew who they were I
know and you know whether you think it's
good or bad for society you know it's
hard to argue against the fact that they
are ultimately extremely successful yeah
is this part of a bigger Trend where you
know we saw uh let's call reality
television or kind of the influencer
world then they started to say hey well
we can do brand deals and advertising
and then they started to say hey we
could do our own products and you know
obviously Kim Kardashian some of our
sisters are are great examples of what
could be built there with these like
influencer Le uh consumer companies is
the next step for all of these people to
then get into the finance game and
actually try to manage very large pools
of capital and ultimately think that's
like the Holy Grail of using your
influence uh to
monetize yeah that's a really
interesting question and I mean I think
over the past five 10 years we've
certainly seen a huge increase in
Celebrity interest in investing in
general you know a lot of that has been
inventure capital A lot of that has been
you know Angel Investing or joining a
startup with some sort of kind of vanity
title as a representative for the brand
um but there are also of course
celebrities who have gone all in you
know Serena Williams and Serena Ventures
Ashton Kutcher is one of the first to
this space um what Kim's doing with sky
is a little unique because it's private
Equity not venture capital and the kind
of scale of the commitment is a little
different you know sky is Raising um
most likely a billion dollar fund um
private Equity requires a yearlong
commitment it's not just you know
writing a check and kind of keeping an
eye out and hoping for the best a couple
years down the line it's really being in
the weeds in the nitty-gritty um in the
years ahead so so you know I think it's
hard for anyone with a day job to make
that kind of commitment whether that job
is in Hollywood or not you know you
don't see a lot of folks who do
something else also doing private Equity
so Kim's in a bit of a unique situation
giving given her status in culture and
the influence she has um but who knows
maybe someone else comes along who sees
the success of Sky if they are
successful and decides to take a queue
from their book yeah that that makes a
ton of sense um were you able to talk to
any investors in the fund other than
kind of the principles and advisers or
or get any sense from the institutional
World whether people were attracted to
this or you know some of the the um
things that are nuanced about it could
be a turnoff yeah you know I spoke to
not investors in the fun not LPS but um
two experts quoted in the story and you
know both of them really um saw the
potential of this idea and you know gave
some insight into the um position it has
in the industry in general so um
investors in the space are you know
really kind of um understanding that you
know this idea is not just kind of a
celebrity vanity play it has some real
potential yeah and when you look at um
the way that Asset Management firms
today Market themselves position
themselves it's still pretty stuffy
right I mean yeah there's a couple that
maybe have broken through from a
branding perspective when Kim Kardashian
does it I'm assuming it's not going to
be pretty stuffy like she's got a style
she's got an understanding of culture
she's got an ability to communicate
using completely new tools like she
doesn't need to go on television to get
her message out she can go right to her
Instagram account or any of the other
platforms do you see the firm innovating
or or kind of doing things differently
when it comes to uh you know the
business practices and kind of taking a
lesson from Kim and just saying hey
let's Port this over and and maybe it
even has an impact on the asset
management space where people start to
replicate some of the things that they
do yeah it's interesting I think they
would definitely say they want to do
things a little differently one thing
that stands out is that they say they do
not want to be associated with private
equity's reputation as kind of a
corporate Raider that comes in and buys
businesses that are in trouble lays
people off and does a total overhaul um
they want to avoid that and you know
that kind of may sound like a little bit
too good to be true like can you really
truly totally avoid that um the thing
that's in their favor is that you know
they do through Kim have access to
really excellent deal flow so there
might be enough deals for them to pursue
that don't fall into that category that
they can avoid it but you know if they
come up with better way of doing private
Equity Kim told me you know that you
don't have to be that way and she
doesn't want to be that way so who knows
if that could have any influence on the
industry it's practices are pretty
entrenched but anything's possible yeah
that's awesome um where can we send
people to find you on the internet or
read the story if they want to read the
whole thing yes please read the story on
fortune.com um my full name is Emma
hinchliff and you can Subs uh subscribe
to my newsletter the broad sheet which
covers women L businesses 5 days a week
via fortune and I'm on Instagram Emma
hin and Twitter _ hinchliff awesome well
thank you so much for doing this you did
a fantastic job and it's pretty cool to
hear kind of the inner workings of what
both Kim Jay and and the rest of the
people at Skype partners are doing so I
appreciate you coming on and we'll do it
again in the future thank you so much
Anthony